from the voice of a beloved children's
cartoon to a star whose career didn't
begin until 50. these actors may be gone
but their mark on the entertainment
world is Everlasting
french actor Gaspar ulio who was best
known to International audiences for his
turn as a young Hannibal Lecter died due
to a skiing accident in January 2022. he
was 37. juliel began his career on
French television in the late 1990s and
was Landing film roles by the early
2000s his big break arrived in 2004 when
he landed a role in A Very Long
Engagement for which he won his first
scissor award his second Cesar came in
2017 when he scooped up best actor for
it's only the end of the world Julio
would make the transition to Hollywood
soon after playing the titular killer in
the 2007 prequel film Hannibal Rising it
was his biggest role at the time of his
death though that likely won't Remain
the case sadly uliel died a few months
before Marvel's Moon Knight dropped in
which he plays Anton mogart AKA Midnight
Man a black market Antiquities dealer
who goes head to head with the titular
hero Peter Robbins who is best known as
the original voice of Charlie Brown died
in January 2022. Dylan Novak Robin's
friend and agent told the Los Angeles
Times that the cause of death was
suicide he was 65. the convention
regular made his screen debut in the 60s
and appeared on TV shows like Rawhide
and The Munsters Robbins began voicing
Charlie Brown in 1965 and went on to
play the classic Peanuts character seven
times before the end of the decade most
notably in the feature-length films A
Charlie Brown Christmas It's the Great
Pumpkin Charlie Brown and a boy named
Charlie Brown according to the times
Robbins was so proud of his work on the
franchise that he got a tattoo of
Charlie Brown and Snoopy on his arm
Robbins was also known for another comic
adaptation he played Alexander Bumstead
on the live-action Blondie series based
on the long-running Strip of the same
name other notable credits include the
TV shows F Troop get smart and My Three
Sons
up and coming actor Moses J Mosley who
appeared on shows like Queen of the
South and The Walking Dead was found
dead in Georgia in January 2022. his
agent Tabitha minchu told The Hollywood
Reporter Moses was a very talented
person with a bright light around him he
will be missed deeply by his friends
family and fans always a ball of happy
energy around him the cause of death was
not immediately revealed by authorities
who launched an investigation to
determine the circumstances he was 31
Mosley worked as a model before
transitioning into acting he got his
foot in the door with a number of
uncredited appearances in films like
Trouble with the Curve the internship
and The Hunger Games Catching Fire
Mosley began playing Michonne's pet
Walker Mike on The Walking Dead in 2012
and would appear on the hit AMC show
half a dozen times over the next few
years his most notable feature film was
2017's attack of the Southern Fried
zombies mostly had several projects in
various stages of production when he was
reported missing by his family
Robert Morse is probably best known to
contemporary audiences for his role as
old school admin and co-founder Bert
Cooper on Mad Men with its 1960s setting
business World plots and one very
memorable musical number madman easily
brings morse's first claim to famed mind
he won a Tony Award in 1962 for his role
as the accidentally successful window
washer turned corporate start J Pierre
Paul Finch and the Broadway musical How
To Succeed In Business Without Really
Trying Morse appeared in many other
stage Productions before and after that
breakthrough hit including the front
page and true a one-man play about
writer Truman Capote which won Morse his
second Tony Award and in Emmy for the TV
adaptation he was all over TV and film
for decades as well including
appearances on Teen Titans Go American
Crime Story and the movie version of How
To Succeed In Business Without Really
Trying on April 20th 2022 Morris's Son
charlie reported to KABC that his father
had died Morse was 90 years old
Mike Haggerty was among the most
prolific and recognizable character
actors of the last 40 years popping up
in more than 100 movies and TV shows he
usually played a Gruff blue-collar
Working Man type with a big mustache and
pronounced Chicago an accent my mom was
right just a big potato with arms and
legs and a head among hagerty's most
familiar roles was Davey the cable TV
station employee in Wayne's World
apartment building superintendent Mr
trigger on Friends the best friend of
the main character in the original
overboard an auto shop owner on Lucky
Louie and a main castor oil on the
George Carlin show Hagerty recently
played a captain on multiple episodes of
Brooklyn Nine-Nine and played farmer Ed
Miller on somebody somewhere on
Instagram somebody somewhere star
Bridget Everett reported that Hagerty
had died on May 5th 2022 in Los Angeles
cause of death wasn't revealed for the
actor who is 67 years old
in a career spanning more than 200 roles
back to the early 1970s Philip Baker
Hall became a quintessential character
actor lending his raspy voice and
intense stare to countless movies and TV
shows Hall became a favorite of
filmmakers relatively late in his career
he's probably best known to audiences as
Lieutenant Joe Buckman a taciturn
Library cop tenaciously investigating
Jerry Seinfeld for a decades overdue
book on the comedian's titular show
you'll also likely recognize him as the
intimidating but secretly sweet neighbor
Walt on Modern Family Dr Morrison on
Curb Your Enthusiasm and hippo game show
host Hank KIPP apopolis on BoJack
Horseman writer director Paul Thomas
Anderson also cast Hall in prominent
roles in Hard Eight and Boogie Nights
Paul's daughter shared that the actor
died at home in Glendale California on
June 12 2022. Hall was 90 years old
while he had a long career as a
character actor for more than 40 years
Gregory Edson was likely best known for
his role on the Smash Hit action drama
24. it's in portrayed Charles Logan a
conniving vice president who finagles
his way into the presidency the part
earned it's in two Emmy Award
nominations one for outstanding
supporting actor in a drama series and
one for guest actor when he returned
late in the 24 run in addition to roles
on various Star Trek shows The Mentalist
NCIS Covert Affairs and Friends itson
performed a bit part in 1980s airplane
as an airport-working cult recruiter
tragically it's in underwent in
emergency surgery in July 2022 but
complications from the procedure proved
fatal he was 74. perhaps the
quintessential supporting actors
specializing in playing elegant but
intimidating Mobsters toys Rico found
the role of his life as Polly walnuts on
HBO's universally acclaimed modern day
Mafia Saga The Sopranos you do what you
told when you told he played similar
characters in Goodfellas Bullets Over
Broadway and mighty Aphrodite his first
filmwork came as an extra in the
organized crime drama crazy Joe sariko
turned to playing fictional lawbreakers
in order to escape a real life of actual
crime he was arrested 28 times as a kid
in young adult and he had connections to
the Colombo crime family in recent years
and after The Sopranos surico traded on
his image and tendency to be Typecast
playing tough characters on comedy shows
like a gangster on American Dad and a
Gruff dog on Family Guy sariko's manager
confirmed to Media Outlets that the
actor died July 8 2022 he was 79. Paul
Sorvino worked in character roles and on
stage throughout the 60s and 70s earning
a Tony nomination for that Championship
season on Broadway in 1973 following a
starring role on the short-lived the
Streets of San Francisco spin-off Bert
D'Angelo Superstar cervino reprized his
role as Phil Romano for the film version
of that Championship season it was his
screen acting breakthrough in 1990
Sorvino landed roles in major movies
that would amount to his signature work
gangster lips manless in the big screen
adaptation of Dick Tracy and as the
paternal calculating mob boss Paulie
Cicero in the crime Saga Goodfellas in
addition to criminals Sorvino played a
lot of authority figures like a sergeant
early in the Run of Law and Order
Juliet's father in bosslerman's Romeo
and Juliet Henry Kissinger in Oliver
Stone's Nixon and Frank Costello in
Godfather of Harlem cervino died on July
25th 2022. according to the actress
publicist natural causes were to blame
Sorvino was 83. Tony Dow is most
remembered for a signature role that
came early in his life and career from
1957 to 1963 he played squeaky clean
1950s teenager Wally Cleaver on Leave it
to Beaver a hit show of the golden age
of TV after Beaver wrapped up Dow played
chet on the melodramatic teen oriented
soap opera never too young but he would
only act occasionally in the decades
thereafter Dao guest starred on shows
like Adam 12 and Murder She Wrote he
frequently returned to the role that
made him famous whether it was
co-starring on the 1980s reboot the new
Leave it to Beaver or sending up his
character in a Kentucky Fried Movie
Cameo Dao segued into a career as TV
show director in the 80s ultimately
helming episodes of shows like coach and
Babylon 5. Dow received a cancer
diagnosis in May 2022 in July 2022 the
actor died at the age of 77. Leslie
Phillips had roles in more than 170
projects in a career that lasted for
well over 80 years and yet yet he's best
known to younger American audiences at
least for a role in which he didn't
appear on screen at all he voiced the
mischievous Sorting Hat in Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer's Stone and Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows part 2.
hmm difficult very difficult other major
career topping performances came in the
drama Venus for which he was nominated
for abafta and other Awards in 2007 and
in 2001's Lara Croft Tomb Raider one of
the most prolific and quintessentially
British actors Phillips often played
British archetypes appearing in made for
TV stage adaptations and in multiple
roles in the long-running carry-on
franchise in the mid-20th century which
lampooned British life and sensibilities
Phillips died in his sleep on November
7th 2022 after a lengthy illness the
actor was 98. Clarence gildier Jr found
success in both acting and Academia on
the educational side of things he earned
his bachelor's degree in acting at
California State University Long Beach
and California State University
Dominguez Hills later on he would earn
an MFA in theater performance at
Southern Methodist University on the
entertainment side Gilyard made his
cinematic debut in 1986's Top Gun
playing the pilot with the call signs
Sundown he would then join one of the
most memorable bad guy crews in action
history teaming up with Alan rickman's
Hans Gruber in Die Hard
yo but he truly endeared himself to TV
fans in Walker Texas Ranger as Chuck
Norris's sidekick Jimmy trivette sadly
Gilyard died in November 2022 at the age
of 66 with the University of Nevada Las
Vegas confirming his death and film
chair Heather Addison saying via
deadline Professor gillyard was a beacon
of light and strength for everyone
around him at UNLV
Hans Slayton Hughes was best known for
playing the incredibly cranky Ethel
beavers on Parks and Recreation Ethel
was a quartz stenographer who was immune
to Tom haverford's charms and was
adopted by Andy in April to be their
grandmother of course that's far from
the only role she played born in 1930
Slayton Hughes didn't begin acting until
age 50. over the years she's popped up
in television shows such as Brooklyn
Nine-Nine new girl Arrested Development
True Blood and The West Wing she also
appeared in movies like the
oscar-nominated good night and good luck
and the Veronica Mars movie Slayton
hughes's death was confirmed by her
family on Facebook on December 8 2022
with a statement that read Helen passed
away last night her pain has ended but
her Fierce Spirit lives on thank you for
the love and support of her work